For spring break, I'm pretty much just going to go back home,
gonna skate a little bit, get to see my chihuahuas again.
I might get a tattoo, but we haven't fully figured that out.
I will be on a trip off of Key West in Florida
on a research cruise for an oceanography class.
I'm headed to Colorado to play some lacrosse games with the MIT Lacrosse team.
I'm going home for a couple days, and then
going to Spain with my two best friends for like a week.
I'm going to be rowing crew here, so I'm gonna be stuck on campus for spring break.
But it's okay. We have a great time on the Charles.
I'm gonna go to Connecticut to go see my girlfriend's parents,
which is exciting, but also a little nerve-wracking.
I'm gonna be going to London with 15 of my best friends.
I'm a member of the Logarhythms. My whole a capella group is going on spring tour.
So I'm in TPP, Technology and Policy Program.
Every year they organize this trip to D.C.,
and we're gonna meet, like, some policymakers down there.
I will be sitting out by the pool as much as possible,
and trying to get a tan. It's not gonna happen, but I will make the attempt.
I am going home tomorrow, which is really exciting. I haven't seen my parents in a while.
So it's nice to, you know, get a break from schoolwork and go back and hang out with family.